c'est quelqu'un qui s'abrite derrière
des grands mots derrière l'écologie
derrière le féminisme en fait pour faire
carrière c'est une ambitieuse qui
élimine tous ces rivaux par le mensonge
par la manipulation comme ça parce que
tu vois moi je l'ai reçu ici avec une
très sympathique
on a l'impression en fait que au
contraire elle dit beaucoup de conneries
qu'elle fait des gaffes tout ça je la
compare à ce personnage dans Tintin et
le lotus bleu vous savez c'est quelqu'un
qui découpe les têtes il s'appelle Didi
et il dit vous allez trouver la voie
mais il faut d'abord que je vous coupe
la tête et il le dit avec un grand
sourire et le grand sourire de Sandrine
Rousseau dissimule une carriériste mais
vraiment sans pitié ensuite il y a ce
qu'elle représente c'est une société du
contrôle une société morale une société
où les hommes sont coupables par
naissance ou la sexualité des hommes et
condamné je parle pas des violences et
des excès je parle de la sexualité en
elle-même est-ce qu'elle prépare comme
modèle de société moi je n'en veux pas
et je m'y oppose sous la forme d'un
pamphlet donc c'est vrai que j'y vais
assez fort alors ça t'a valu quelques
critiques qu'on a vu Cécile Duflot tiens
samedi soir sur France 2 elle a pris de
la défense de Sandrine Rousseau
c'est normal
arrête avec ça
mais qu'il espère que ça lui fasse
vendre des livres donc c'est un vrai
sujet les combats féministes dans
l'histoire ils ont toujours des rangés
je sais que il faut des voix plus
réelles pour mener des combats
difficiles il y a des gens qui sont plus
modérés plus calmes et il y a des gens
qui font de manière plus brutale elle a
choisi cette manière de faire et je
comprends ça et en tout cas monsieur
nolo ce qui me permet de me faire
interrompre par vous toutes les 30
secondes c'est à dire d'être à 6 ici
c'est que des femmes ont passé pendant
des années il y a 100 ans pour des
hystériques pour des insupportables
parce que ces femmes à l'époque on les
traitait de la même manière que vous
traitez aujourd'hui Sandrine Rousseau et
donc je sais que c'est grâce à elle que
moi je peux être en disant je suis
modérée
ça c'est très intéressant le monde que
veulent imposer Sandrine Rousseau et
Cécile Duflot c'est un nom de toute
critique envers une femme sera
considérée comme un comportement c'est
ça misogyne par principe moi si mon
sujet avait été un homme j'y serai allé
tout aussi fort il y a un métier sur des
hommes toi jamais été bien sûr mais en
plus c'est un féminisme contre-productif
qu'est-ce que propose Sandrine Rousseau
comme modèle une des phrases les plus
incroyables qu'elle est prononcées c'est
je préfère les jeteuses de sort donc les
sorcières aux ingénieurs européennes
c'est-à-dire qu'elle considère que les
femmes devraient rester dans leur
cuisine en train de touiller des filtres
magiques pendant que les hommes font des
grandes études est-ce que c'est ça le
féminisme que nous voulons est-ce que
nous voulons des femmes dans les
cuisines en train de comploter entre
sorcières ou est-ce que nous voulons que
les femmes fassent des études
supérieures comme tous les hommes
évidemment la réponse est évidente alors
il y a eu beaucoup de critiques voilà
concernant ça après c'est toujours les
mêmes on va pas ah oui ça oui voilà
c'est toujours les mêmes donc voilà
c'est normal juste tu t'y attendais oui
je sais parce qu'on peut pas déranger le
politiquement correct puisque ces gens
là ne veulent pas débattre ils vous
diabolisent immédiatement vous devenez
sexisme misogyne et ça s'arrête pas là
après il vous traite de fasciste j'en
suis pas encore arrivé un nazi mais je
pense que c'est dans les prochains jours
alors d'abord j'adore le penser au
vitriol et c'est formidable mais de la
même manière que elle elle veut
déconstruire l'homme quelque part tu
veux déconstruire Sandrine Rousseau mais
est-ce que toi tu penses pas que
finalement elle se déconstruit toute
seule parce qu'en fait elle représente
quoi Sandrine rousse au final alors moi
je pense que Cyril a raison elle
représente rien du tout ça va bien sur
les petits plateaux télés comme ça même
pas ici d'ailleurs mais son idée en fait
même pas oui mais elle est venue ici le
dernier sondage crudité de la primaire à
la primaire des écolos elle a même pas
gagné et celui qui a gagné la primaire
des écolos il a fait moins de 5 donc en
fait ça représente rien n'est qu'une
dans les médias oui et non est-ce que je
veux dire en fait est-ce que je peux lui
donner trop d'importance oui non parce
que elle est complètement has bean
finalement oui mais l'homme n'y présence
médiatique est quand même troublante et
surtout la manière dont elle est traitée
quand elle quand elle accuse
publiquement un de ces rivaux
écologiques de l'avoir violemment
bousculé on lui passe les images
Eric Piol puisqu'il s'agit des ripoles
passe en fait à 3 mètres d'elle et là ça
lui très aimablement personne sur le
plateau lui dit est-ce que vous avez
menti même elle bénéficie d'une forme
d'impunité médiatique le mensonge une
répétition personne ne lui met le nez
dans ce monde
et moi je m'en cache pas j'ai souvent
invité et d'ailleurs on l'a reçu ici
parce que aussi c'est c'est une bonne
cliente en télé tu vois tu le sais donc
beaucoup beaucoup l'invite parce qu'on
se dit on va avoir une petite phrase
bien sûr on va la faire réagir à deux
trois petits trucs elle va sortir
forcément bien sûr une connerie ça va
nous faire rire ça va être pris le
lendemain mais c'est vrai on le sait
donc elle va faire une gaffe donc voilà
donc tout le monde essaie d'inviter elle
vient voilà
en plus quand tu es le début moi elle
était sympa j'avais bien aimé après
après c'est vrai voilà après après je
suis c'est vrai qu'elle est voilà c'est
compliqué elle a dit des choses qui peut
être compliqué elle en fait
la petite phrase un moment un moment un
moment on commence à ça commence à se
voir que c'est un petit peu du mytho
voilà s'il aime bien riche Verdun
monsieur Naulleau madame Rousseau sans
hésiter ce sera Sandrine Rousseau
sans problème
moi je suis de la gauche authentique et
Gilles Verdez j'ai de la gauche alors
évidemment c'est pas la même chose c'est
pas la même chose
tes révolutionnaire tu es pas de gauche
mais pas les gens de gauche parce que
c'est Mélenchon les révolutionnaire il
est pas de gauche moi je suis de gauche
non t'es pas de gauche tes
révolutionnaire
c'est pas du tout pareil
Eric et gauche
le problème c'est qu'il n'a pas été
peut-être de gauche la dernière action
si les personnes mais moi je me
revendique de gauche évidemment bah oui
Emmanuel Macron c'est qu'il était de
gauche
alors elle est excessive comme sur
Julien Bayo d'accord
tu trouves que c'est seulement excessif
sur Julien Bayou elle lui a flingué sa
vie
au téléspectateurs l'affaire Julien
Bayou parce que je commence mon livre
avec ça exactement voilà donc est-ce que
tu peux nous rappeler
Eric parce que Julien bazouzi Bayou
c'est le secrétaire écologie elle date
c'est une affaire inouïe sur un plateau
de télévision elle accuse Julien Bayou
en fait d'être un prédateur qui pousse
les femmes au suicide c'est ça elle dit
d'ailleurs il y a une enquête le
journaliste me dit une enquête policière
non une enquête journalistique j'ai lu
l'enquête j'en ai igna absolument rien
aucune femme finalement n'apportait
plainte et le dossier est entièrement
vide mais résultat
sur la base d'un mensonge et d'une
manipulation si c'est ça la gauche
comme ça
exactement mais
si vous la laisse rester avec cette
gauche du mensonge voir non mais si tu
peux recevoir
même pas de moi c'est pareil on est
pareil non juste manger je t'aime
beaucoup mais à partir de ce moment-là
pour moi c'est fini c'est
disqualification c'est fini et même nous
en vrai on ne devrait même plus
l'inviter je le dis voilà je le dis et
c'est vrai que c'est disqualification
direct le gars tu sais tu te rends
compte pour sa famille regarde le gars
il a fait les titres partout le
lendemain il était engroté parce que
aussi ce qui se passe c'est que tout le
monde a repris derrière et puis il faut
voir l'article qui déballe toute sa vie
privée avec des histoires de petites
culottes et tout enfin horrible quoi le
sordide total mais Verdez dit c'est Mago
bon donc pour moi c'est juste une erreur
faute politique
c'est pas possible aujourd'hui
tu arrêtes elle a encore
une écoute dans l'opinion et j'avais
aucune écoute je l'invite moi aussi on
l'invite c'est parce que c'est comme
gros
[Applaudissements]
rugby dis-moi voilà les deux mais
Sandrine Rousseau elle dérange parce
qu'elle a une vision plus juste plus
égalitaire elle est pas longue de bois
elle a pas une manière de faire une
vision totalitaire on voulait la manière
dont elle aborde la cheville si vous
voulez c'est pareil mais c'est
extraordide
ton cerveau dans un grille-pain c'est
pas possible attendez non je veux juste
une chose le plus le plus grave je parle
à un homme de gauche enfin prétendument
de gauche c'est que mais moi on a au
contraire moi je suis très heureux que
j'ai gardé soit non de gauche
c'est pas un homme de gauche c'est
Nicolas
pour qui tu veux et vous avez j'ai
jamais jugé personne et vous pouvez
voter pour qui vous voulez vraiment
alors vraiment on est je me mets jamais
à la place des électeurs et mais Gilles
parfois est un peu discernement moi ce
qui me dérange c'est pas qu'elle soit de
gauche de droite c'est qu'elle a tué la
carrière d'un homme je suis désolé mais
pas seulement pas que le plus grave
c'est que par ses excès par ces bourdes
par ses mensonges par ces manipulations
elle détournent des millions de gens de
l'écologie et du féminisme les gens se
disent c'est ça l'écologie c'est ça le
féminisme c'est une aux autres comme ça
et ben je vais voter ailleurs donc elle
est absolument contre-productif donc
même si vous êtes un homme de gauche mon
cher Verdez vous devriez apprécier le
rôle néfaste que je vous devriez vous
révolter un truc parce que je voudrais
remettre ça je voudrais mettre les les
points sur les i ce soit aussi parce que
j'aurais rappelé sur Éric parce que j'en
ai marre de lire aussi des trucs sur
Eric et cetera c'est un homme de gauche
non mais je te le dis non
qui n'est pas un homme de gauche
je l'ai toujours été je le saurai
toujours et les autres
trucs avait des sidérations
antisémites racistes homophobes je peux
vous dire il n'aurait jamais fait une
émission avec moi voilà
j'aime beaucoup je ne connais pas ses
idées mais pardon aussi à ce qui est ce
que ce que vous êtes est-ce que vous
montrez et pour les gens je reconnais
quand vous allez au premier rang du
mythique de Zemmour non mais pardon dans
la migraine mais c'est ce que tu fais tu
peux pas reprocher aux gens après on te
voit soutenir Zemmour et après tu dis je
suis de gauche je vais pas soutenu
une bonne fois pour toute combien de
fois dans la vie il arrive qu'un de vos
copains soient candidats à la présidence
de la République il m'invite à son
meeting je vais au meeting parce que je
m'assois où je veux mais tu sais
personne qui peut me dire où je m'assois
ce sont les hôtesses de l'air et les
ouvreuses de terre
[Applaudissements]
si j'avais été un soutien de Zemmour je
serai allé à la tribune j'étais bien
Éric il fait il fait ce qu'il veut y
aller moi je vais tenir je m'entends je
m'entendais très bien avec tous les
candidats
mais c'est vrai que voilà il a pas mal
aussi avec qui je m'entends très bien
qu'ils m'ont demandé d'aller dans leur
meeting ça voilà moi je suis pas allé
parce que voilà je parce que je me suis
dit voilà comme et c'est aussi autre
chose on va croire que je soutenir moi
je suis allé j'y vais nulle part voilà
mais est-ce que tu est-ce que tu as fait
passer ton amitié avant tes idées
politiques c'est ça absolument je
voulais voir ça c'était un événement
très important à l'époque c'était même
un événement qui était présenté comme
même à risque il y avait une tension moi
je voulais être là j'étais là il me
semble que la présence d'un ami au
premier rang oui mais pas un scandale
pas qu'on te demande de justifier
un petit truc parce que j'ai envie comme
ça qu'on mette les choses au clair là je
te dis tout on se connaît depuis
longtemps
il y a beaucoup des idées d'Éric Zemmour
il y en a beaucoup qui te dérange non
notamment ce qui peut dire sur sur
l'islam etc ça te dérange mais personne
au monde n'a autant contredire eczéma
j'ai fait 15 ans et équipe avec Eric
Zemmour donc je le contredisais chaque
semaine personne au monde ne peut se
vanter d'un pari bilan regardez les
archives nous sommes en désaccord sur
des tas de points fondamentaux dont
l'Islam évidemment mais mais pas le seul
donc ce procès en plus ce procès n'est
jamais clos quoi ça recommence à chaque
fois avec les mêmes arguments mais alors
Villepin etc etc je l'anémie pas je m'en
suis expliqué une fois dix fois 100 fois
je viens de le faire une 101e fois je
sais que j'aurais à le faire une 102e
fois pour moi c'est absurde mais c'est
pas grave c'est juste qu'il faut pas
encore une fois si tu vas quelque part
tu sais que tu es un homme public et
qu'on va te voir après les gens te
voient est associe tu peux mettre
derrière arrêtez m'associer à ça tu es
allé gilberté c'est un ami j'irai jamais
son meeting
j'aimerais bien voir un meeting de
Gilles Verdun avec quand même madame
Rousseau un taliban oui le mot que vous
employez bien lu de toute façon
extrêmement violent ensuite Cyril si
vous le permettez parce que c'est juste
ou pas parce que la question c'est pas
la violence on peut pas comparer je vais
vous dire que si je vais vous donner un
exemple ça c'est pour moi les talibans
les aliments il détestent tout ce qu'il
y avait avant eux donc ils ont dynamité
les Bouddha dans les pays dans les pays
où ils ont pris le pouvoir et Madame
Rousseau elle pense qu'au nom de la
cause écolo on peut s'en prendre à des
œuvres d'art des tableaux de Van Gogh
c'est la même chose c'est exactement
là-bas
c'est très difficile de discuter avec
Verdun parce que Verdez je représente la
gauche totalitaire voilà ce sont des
gauches des gauchos staliniens
c'est-à-dire vous avez Mélenchon qui dit
ah bah la République vous avez Verdez ce
qui dit mais bien sûr qu'il faut
détruire les tableaux de Van Gogh au nom
de je ne sais quel est donc ce sont des
gens totalitaires qui veulent imposer
par la force
quand tu dis un mec un cambrioleur il
vient chez lui il faut bien qu'il vienne
chez lui il vole tout mais par contre il
réveille pas sa femme
j'ai dit j'ai dit que ça ferait pas de
mal de réécrire un peu l'histoire de
déboulonner certaines statuts etc mais
voilà je pense que je le partage avec
Madame Rousseau mais ce sont des
convictions elles ont quand même mon
prochain pamphlet ce sera sur Verdun
parce que c'est une mine d'or
c'est mon ami s'il y avait que des mecs
comme ça chez nous ah non mais je te
jure mais tu sais que déjà que c'est
compliqué en France aujourd'hui s'il y
avait que des gars comme ça mais c'est
la série on va dans le mur c'est parfois
d'accord avec Gilles mais là quand tu
viens de dire quelque chose qui moi
vient de me faire sortir de mes gonds
réécrire l'histoire on ne réécrit pas du
tout non non non non c'est vrai que
l'histoire ça veut dire la nier et la
réinventer une histoire
on apprend ses erreurs on dit où il y a
eu des erreurs et on avance et on
superposés
derrière tes grandes idées tu manges
généreux avec des squatteurs et tout et
on voit que tu es vraiment
alors
juste pour répondre à Valérie c'est une
histoire qui a été écrite sans les
minorités sans la diversité qui a été
inscrit qui a été écrite avec le
colonialisme et l'esclavage il faut
réécrire cette histoire 1984 c'est
exactement le roman 199
erreurs mais tu peux pas réécrire
l'histoire dans 1984 le grand roman
anti-totalité le pouvoir en place passe
son temps à réécrire l'histoire vous
seriez très à l'aise dans ce roman mais
pas en tant que critique en tant que
personnage et si je peux alors répondre
quel est le rapport quel est le rapport
laissez-moi finir moi je suis bien mis
avec toi
non mais franchement
c'est mon ami et pourtant je ne supporte
tout ce qui dit tout ce qu'il dit je
pense le contraire on est pratiquement
et je peux pas le blairer
plus dangereux et demain demain il fait
super qu'il se représentera jamais
demain tu fais une réunion tout ça ou tu
vas dire des choses exetera tu peux être
sûr et certain que je ne viendrai pas
non non non non non non mais tu es mon
ami non mais tu es mon ami mais donc non
mais l'exemple il est bon parce que toi
tu es mon ami et je suis complètement
opposé à tout ce que tu dis sauf que il
n'y a pas de sauf que personne ne nous
deux
mais contre d'une manière vraiment
l'islam et les musulmans n'a été
condamné pour des choses graves et quand
on lit de gauche être amis avec
quelqu'un d'extrême droite qui est
contre l'islam et les musulmans je ne
comprends pas ce nouveau combat
je comprends vos confrontations et
éditoriales sur des plateaux avec lui le
débat parfait
Eric Zemmour
que vous soyez amis avec quelqu'un qui
pense globalement que l'islam et les
musulmans sont de trop je ne comprends
pas donc je comprends pas que vous
soutiez monsieur Mélanie comment
pouvez-vous être le soutien de Monsieur
Mélenchon qui lui aussi a été condamné
avec qui sympathise avant d'être
vraiment amis demande pour qui l'a voté
autrement c'est pas des amis avec des
gens et toi tu soutiens un Mélenchon ou
des gens qui sont c'est pas évolution
c'est pas mon ami
c'est un soutien de Monsieur Mélenchon
qui lui aussi a été condamné c'est un
soutien Monsieur Mélenchon qui tient un
discours anti républicain qui frôle de
plus en plus
el à
l'insurrections
vous soutenez la violence vous soutenez
des gens pour qui le pouvoir de se prend
pas dans les urnes mais dans la rue et
par la violence et vous venez me donner
des cours vous êtes vous êtes amis vous
êtes un représentant malheureusement de
quelque chose que je croyais disparu
tout est dans le mur tout est à côté
tout est hors sujet alors comment on a
pas le temps de tout reprendre si vous
avez quelque chose d'intéressant à dire
que maintenant quelqu'un qui déteste les
musulmans
j'en ai discuté 20 fois avec lui je ne
suis pas d'accord avec lui sur
l'islamation
je le contredis je le contre du plaisir
de l'extrême droite
dans le monde que l'extrême droite
on se reverra on se reverra au goulag
sauf que vous vous serez gardien et moi
je prépare des prisonniers voilà ce qui
va se passer je vous donnerai à manger
merci beaucoup je te dis c'est ton pire
plateau de l'année